When I was in my 20s, I worked as a temp typist on the overnight shift. And it was one of my favorite jobs I ever had. I showed up at work at midnight. Downtown was completely dark. Nobody on the streets at all. And I'd take the elevator to the, you know, 20th floor or whatever it was. And it would be all lit up and bustling with activity, dozens of people rushing around. Usually we were hustling out some kind of legal brief or exhibit for court the next day.
二十多岁时，我曾做过夜班兼职打字员。那是我最喜欢的工作之一。我午夜上班，市中心一片漆黑，街上空无一人。我坐电梯到20楼左右，那里灯火通明，忙碌异常，几十个人匆忙走动。我们通常是在赶制第二天的法庭简报或证据材料。
I loved being up when the rest of the world was asleep. And the next morning, when I would walk to the subway as the sun was coming up, I loved knowing that everybody else on the street was dragging themselves to their jobs and I was done for the day. It was like I was part of a secret society that's alive in the middle of the night.
我喜欢在全世界沉睡时醒着。第二天早上，当我在日出时分走向地铁，我很享受这种感觉：街上其他人正拖着疲惫的身体去上班，而我已经结束了一天的工作。我就像是一个在深夜里活跃的秘密组织成员。
OK. Everybody, go home. We're about to start this.
好了，各位，回家吧。我们要开始录制了。
It's a regular thing for Austin and his high school friends at night. The pile into a Honda Odyssey minivan. They remove the backseats and drive around the Northern California suburbs, fake-kidnapping their buddies. 15 of them.
这对奥斯汀和他的高中朋友们来说是晚上的常态。他们挤进一辆本田奥德赛面包车，拆掉后座，在北加州的郊区兜风，假装绑架他们的伙伴。一共15个人。
Open the door! Open the door!
开门！开门！
Did you get him?
抓住他了吗？
Get in the back.
坐到后面去。
Everybody in?
都上来了吗？
Opa!
奥帕！
The fake kidnapping is all part of a tradition that they've made up. They call it "going out living" or "living a little." It's not the weekend. The whole point of this is do this on a boring Monday or Tuesday or Thursday night. A school night when other people aren't out having fun.
这种假绑架是他们自创传统的一部分。他们称之为“出去生活”或“活出点滋味”。这不是在周末，重点就在于要在无聊的周一、周二或周四晚上做这件事。在别人都不出来玩的工作日晚上。
There's no destination. It's basically just glorified cruising. They drive around for hours, talking about whatever, singing along to the music. [SINGING]
没有目的地，本质上就是高级版的兜风。他们开车转悠好几个小时，随心所欲地聊天，跟着音乐唱歌。[歌唱]
They bring their minivan to the top of a hill and put it in neutral, and then they all rock back and forth inside the van in unison until finally it rolls down the hill.
他们把车开到山顶，挂上空挡，然后大家在车里齐声前后晃动，直到车子最终滑下山坡。
Whoa!
哇！
And then sometime after 1 AM, Ian, the driver, pulls out the soundtrack to the Disneyland ride Space Mountain. He's worked out a way to drive in sync with the soundtrack, to simulate the actual ride.
凌晨1点多，司机伊恩会拿出迪士尼太空山游乐项目的原声带。他摸索出了一种配合音乐节奏驾驶的方法，以此来模拟真实的游乐体验。
Yeah. We're in the car driving very slowly up this dark hill.
是的，我们在车里在这座漆黑的山坡上开得很慢。
This is Austin.
这是奥斯汀。
The headlights are very low. This kind of eerie music. Everyone's a little bit nervous, because you're about to do something-- probably the most dangerous thing we do.
车灯调得很低。音乐阴森森的。每个人都有点紧张，因为你即将要做的事情——可能是我们做过的最危险的事。
Launch control, LV. Go ahead. All video recorders off. Roger.
发射控制，LV，请讲。所有摄像机已关闭。收到。
At this point he flips on his emergency lights and starts speeding up a little bit up the hill, turns the car around. Lets the car roll down the hill, accelerating all the way. His lights are turning on and off, on and off, on and off. Driving very, very quickly, at this point, around turns.
这时，他打开应急灯，开始在山坡上加速，掉转车头。让车顺着山坡滑下，全程加速。他的车灯一闪一闪的。此时，车速飞快地过弯。
So basically, you're going down a hill?
所以基本上，你们是在下坡？
Yeah. We're going down a very steep, windy hill.
对，我们在一条非常陡峭、弯曲的山路上行驶。
It's remote enough, by the way, that in a year of doing this, they have never even seen another car.
顺便说一下，这里很偏僻，做这件事的一年里，他们甚至从没见过另一辆车。
None of this would be fun during the daytime, Austin says. At night, nobody sees you. You can do anything.
奥斯汀说，白天做这些一点意思都没有。晚上没人看见你，你可以做任何事。
Late at night is kind of the whole fun of the event. People don't really pay attention to who's doing what at night.
深夜正是活动的乐趣所在。人们晚上根本不会注意是谁在做什么。
[SINGING]
[歌唱]
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our show, we spend an hour with the secret society that is up in the middle of the night. All the people doing things that they would never do during the daytime, and the people doing things that they might be during the day that just feel different when you do them at night. Moving products, and hauling across a war zone, and caring for sick kids, and just wandering the streets to get out of the house. Everything is different at night. We witness how in five acts. Stay with us.
今天，我们节目将花一个小时走进深夜里活跃的秘密社会。所有那些人们在白天绝不会做的事情，以及人们在白天做同样的事情但晚上做感觉却完全不同的事情。运输货物、穿越战区、照顾生病的孩子，或者仅仅是出门四处游荡以逃离家门。到了晚上，一切都变得不同。我们将通过五个篇章见证这一点。请继续收听。
Act One. Orange You Glad I Didn't Say Banana?
第一幕：我没说香蕉你高兴吗？
To get to the Hunts Point Market, you drive through this industrial part of the South Bronx, and at night, it's abandoned. For miles, you pass all these closed auto repair lots and plumbing supply stores. And then you go through a fence, pass some pretty intense security, drive a bit more, and suddenly, boom. You are in the Hunts Point Terminal Market.
要到亨茨角市场，你需要穿过南布朗克斯的工业区，晚上那里是一片荒凉。你经过数英里关闭的汽车修理厂和管道用品店，然后穿过一道围栏，经过严格的安检，再往前开一点，突然，砰！你就在亨茨角批发市场里了。
And it's like a busy city at rush hour. Bright and loud. Forklifts whipping around, carrying pallets to trucks. Warehouses in long rows, several city blocks long. 60 acres of produce.
这里就像繁忙城市的早高峰一样，明亮而喧闹。叉车飞快地穿梭，运送着托盘到卡车上。仓库排列成行，有好几个街区那么长。60英亩的农产品。
When people arrive here at 10 PM to work, what they say to each other is "good morning," because the middle of the night is when the most of the business gets done.
当人们在晚上10点来到这里工作时，他们互相打招呼的方式是“早上好”，因为大部分生意都是在深夜完成的。
Two members of the team of economics reporters at Planet Money, Adam Davidson and Chana Joffe-Walt usually report on financial markets and derivative markets and currency markets, so they were pleased to get a chance to actually visit a market what people buy and sell stuff that you can see and touch and smell. Here they are.
Planet Money经济记者团队的两名成员，亚当·戴维森和查娜·乔夫-沃尔特，通常报道金融市场、衍生品市场和货币市场，所以他们很高兴有机会参观一个人们买卖看得见、摸得着、闻得到的真实商品市场。他们来了。
Eddie One-Way needs some pears.
埃迪·单行道需要一些梨。
His name is actually Edward Joseph. They call him "Eddie One-Way" because he wants prices to go one way-- down. He's a buyer, one of thousands of guys who show up here every night.
他的真名叫爱德华·约瑟夫。大家叫他“埃迪·单行道”，因为他希望价格只往一个方向走——下跌。他是买家，是每晚出现在这里的成千上万个人中的一员。
And they're buying for pretty much every grocery store, restaurant, corner market in the northeast. If you have ever bought a Golden Delicious apple or ate a salad in a restaurant between Philly and Boston, chances are it came through here.
他们为东北部的每一家杂货店、餐馆、街角小店购买货物。如果你曾在费城和波士顿之间买过金冠苹果或在餐厅吃过沙拉，很可能它就是从这里流出的。
And it is nothing like when you or I buy a salad at a restaurant. There are no posted prices. It us pure supply and demand.
这和你我在餐厅买沙拉完全不同。这里没有标价，纯粹是供需关系。
And right now, demand-- that's Eddie One-Way, the buyer-- is looking for supply.
现在，需求方——就是买家埃迪·单行道——正在寻找供应。
Let's see here, where's my salesman? Oh, Mr. Timmy?
让我看看，我的推销员在哪？哦，提米先生？
Timmy is a salesman at one of the wholesalers here, to Rigo Brothers.
提米是这里的一家批发商Rigo兄弟的推销员。
He's close by. I think he's in one of these refrigerators.
他就在附近，我想他在其中一个冷库里。
This place here is a stadium. I think you need GPS to get around here. It would help.
这个地方就像个体育场，我觉得你需要GPS才能转得开。这会有帮助。
Eventually, Eddie One-Way finds Timmy, and they enter into a ritual that will happen thousands of times throughout the night. They try to negotiate a price.
最终，埃迪找到了提米，他们开始了一场整晚会上演成千上万次的仪式。他们试图讨价还价。
Eddie thinks $15 for a box of pears seems fair. Timmy doesn't.
埃迪觉得一箱梨15美元很合理，但提米不这么认为。
No way.
没门。
We could do it--
我们可以——
I told you 20 yesterday.
我昨天跟你说了是20。
Yesterday's gone. Today's a new day.
昨天已经过去了，今天又是新的一天。
$20 yesterday, 18 today. That's it.
昨天20，今天18，就这价。
Stay close, Timmy.
留步，提米。
Timmy offers Eddie a different kind of pear for $15, which to me looked exactly the same.
提米给了埃迪另一种梨，要价15美元，在我看来它们长得一模一样。
$15 on these, $18 on them.
这些15美元，那些18美元。
But Eddie One-Way knows things about pears that I will never know, and he ignores that ridiculous offer.
但埃迪·单行道对梨的了解是我永远无法企及的，他无视了这个荒谬的报价。
Why do you want to pay $15? Why is 18--?
为什么你要付15？为什么18就——？
I'd like to pay 13, but I'm being generous.
我想付13，但我已经在慷慨解囊了。
All right. That's it, brother. That's it, man. 18 is the right number. You know it's what they're worth.
行了，兄弟，就这价，伙计。18是公道价，你知道它们就值这么多。
The night's still young.
夜还长着呢。
Eventually Eddie One-Way walks away. The night is still young. At this hour the sellers, guys like Timmy, feel like they are in control. They don't want to give anything away too cheap yet. There's lots more buyers still to come. But Eddie, the buyer, is hoping that if he comes back later in the night, Timmy won't have sold that much. He'll be desperate to get rid of his pears, and will accept a lower price. But Eddie's really taking a risk here.
最终埃迪走开了。夜还长着呢。在这个钟点，像提米这样的卖家感觉自己掌控着局面。他们不想太早降价，还有更多的买家会来。但买家埃迪希望如果他晚些时候回来，提米还没卖掉那么多货。他会急于清理梨子，从而接受更低的价格。但埃迪确实在冒险。
I know. I actually saw this risk play out with carrots, and it was really stressful. Jeff Steinberg is a buyer like Eddie, and he was looking for this one particular kind of carrot. A fancy one. Loose California. And I followed him around, walking the aisles, one seller to another. And at first, everyone has the carrots, but Jeff is offended-- or at least acts offended-- by the high prices. And then an hour passes. And now nobody has Loose Californias anymore. Jeff can't find the carrots he needs at any price. So he's thinking he may have to settle for something inferior-- Loose Canadians.
我知道，我亲眼看到这种风险发生在胡萝卜身上，真的让人压力很大。杰夫·斯坦伯格是像埃迪一样的买家，他在寻找一种特殊的胡萝卜，那种散装的加州胡萝卜。我跟着他逛遍了各个通道，从一个卖家到另一个卖家。起初，每个人都有货，但杰夫对高价感到不满——或者至少表现出不满。一小时过去了，现在没人有那种散装加州胡萝卜了。杰夫无论出多少钱都买不到他需要的胡萝卜。他不得不考虑退而求其次——散装加拿大胡萝卜。
Eugh.
呃。
Jeff asks a seller named Carlos how much for the Loose Canadians. Carlos tells him eight bucks a box.
杰夫问一个叫卡洛斯的卖家散装加拿大胡萝卜多少钱。卡洛斯告诉他八块钱一箱。
I'll be right back, then.
那我待会儿再来。
What's he doing now?
他现在在做什么？
Going to look at something that he's going to come back and tell me he doesn't like.
去看看别的东西，然后回来说他不满意。
What does it mean that he's not going to like it?
他说他不满意是什么意思？
Probably because they're not good enough for his customers. He's fairly picky, so you have to give the right people the right stuff.
可能是因为质量达不到他客户的要求。他很挑剔，所以你必须给对的人提供对的东西。
And sure enough, Jeff comes out of the warehouse, shaking his head.
果不其然，杰夫走出仓库，摇着头。
No good.
不行。
No good? And where are you going to look for carrots next?
不行？那你接下来打算去哪找胡萝卜？
That's a good question, because I've pretty much looked all over the place.
问得好，因为我基本上已经把所有地方都找遍了。
So it's 11:30 at night, and carrots are your problem at the moment.
现在是晚上11:30，胡萝卜成了你目前的问题。
At the moment. It's coming down to that hour where I'm probably going to have to pay what they wanted, what I don't want to pay.
目前是这样。快到那个钟点了，我可能不得不支付他们想要的价格，即使我不愿意。
Around midnight, it starts to get hectic. Buyers fill the streets. Sellers wave their arms and yell into faces and cell phones. There's a lot of sweating. And as the minutes pass, all these little stories emerge.
午夜左右，市场开始变得混乱。街道挤满了买家。卖家挥舞着手臂，对着人脸和手机大喊大叫。到处都是汗水。随着时间流逝，各种小故事层出不穷。
Midnight, the big story-- tomatoes. They're on fire. Yesterday they were selling for $15. Now they're $25. Everyone is buying.
午夜，大新闻是西红柿。火得不行。昨天还是15美元，现在涨到25美元。所有人都在抢购。
Also breaking this hour-- leafy greens from California. They're huge, because as everyone says, they have weather out there. There's not enough leafy greens coming to satisfy the demand.
同样火爆的还有加州的绿叶蔬菜。需求量极大，正如大家所说，因为那边天气好。绿叶蔬菜的供应满足不了需求。
It's around this time that we meet Angela Poricelli. Angela is the only woman we see the entire night. She says she knows of only one other woman who works here alongside something like 7,000 men.
大约在这个时候，我们遇到了安吉拉·波里切利。安吉拉是我们整晚看到的唯一一名女性。她说她只知道这里有另一位女性，与大约7000名男性在这里工作。
Her booth is decorated with pictures. She has a big cross. She brings in fresh flowers every week.
她的摊位装饰着照片，挂着一个大十字架。她每周都会带新鲜花束来。
She offered me candy. And hanging out with her, we learned that it's not all business here in the middle of the night. We keep seeing her next door neighbor, Henry Polio, stopping by on all sorts of dubious missions. Right now he's looking for a fork.
她请我吃了糖果。和她在一起，我们了解到在深夜这里不仅仅是生意。我们一直看到她的邻居亨利·波利奥过来，进行各种可疑的任务。现在他在找一把叉子。
Hello.
你好。
Do you have a fork?
你有叉子吗？
Yes, I do.
有。
She's the loveliest woman in the market. Believe me, she's the most wonderful person in the world. I know  who her family is. Our family, grandfathers know grandfathers, fathers knew fathers. Wonderful woman.
她是市场上最可爱的女人。相信我，她是世界上最棒的人。我知道她的家人是谁。我们的祖父认识祖父，父亲认识父亲。了不起的女人。
Thank you, Henry.
谢谢你，亨利。
All right.
好。
Bye.
再见。
When you buy a few hundred pounds of fruit or vegetables, there is so much you don't know. What's the quality? How long has it been on the truck? Is the price reasonable? And it's true-- sellers and buyers who don't know each other that well, they lie to each other all the time.
当你购买几百磅水果或蔬菜时，有很多你是不知道的。质量如何？在卡车上待了多久？价格合理吗？确实如此——那些不太熟悉的卖家和买家，他们一直在互相撒谎。
So with all this uncertainty, there is tremendous economic value in long-term, trusting relationships.
所以，在所有这些不确定性中，长期且相互信任的关系具有巨大的经济价值。
Hey Adam? You're overthinking it it's so much simpler than that.
嘿，亚当？你想得太多了，事情远比那简单。
I followed Henry from Angela's back to his booth.
我跟着亨利从安吉拉那回到他的摊位。
You kind of have a crush on Angela?
你是不是对安吉拉有点好感？
No, I do, since I'm a kid. But she always said no.
不，我是，从我小时候就是。但她总是拒绝。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. I want to take her upstairs and she don't to.
是啊。我想带她去楼上，但她不肯。
Have you ever asked her out?
你约过她出去吗？
No, no, no.
没有，没有。
Does she know that you're interested?
她知道你对她有意思吗？
Oh, she knows. I tell her.
哦，她知道。我告诉过她。
You've worked next door to her for all these years and you're never been out with her?
你在她隔壁工作了这么多年，却从未和她出去过？
No! And I ain't going to.
没有！我永远也不会。
Why?
为什么？
Because It's not the right thing to do. She's my sister.
因为那是不对的。她是我的姐妹。
She's not your sister.
她不是你姐妹。
Well, she's close to it.
嗯，差不多了。
You're not with anybody.
你现在有伴吗？
Who, me? Yeah, I got a wife.
我？我有老婆。
Actually, I followed up. Henry doesn't have a wife. He did, but his marriage fell apart. And he blames the night shift for that. They never saw each other. He says all these guys here have wives they never see, kids never see.
事实上，我追问了一下。亨利没有老婆。他曾有过，但婚姻破裂了。他把这归咎于夜班。他们从不见面。他说这里的这些人都有着几乎不见面的老婆，孩子也从不见面。
So I go back to Angela's, and turns out she's also divorced. She raised two boys on her own. And she says, yeah. The night shift definitely gets in the way of life.
于是我回到安吉拉那儿，结果发现她也离婚了。她独自抚养两个男孩。她说，是的，夜班确实阻碍了生活。
I remember my father. There's a lot of things he couldn't make it. On Sundays, if there was a wedding, he couldn't go. Sundays, work. My graduation, too, was on a Friday, and he couldn't come.
我还记得我的父亲。有很多事情他都错过了。周日如果有婚礼，他去不了。周日要工作。我的毕业典礼在周五，他也来不了。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. But that's OK. I understood.
是的。但没关系，我理解。
So Henry, he said you'll never go out with them because you think of him as a brother.
那么亨利说你永远不会和他出去是因为你把他当哥哥。
Yes. I agree with him there. That I do. Plus, I'm engaged to someone right now. His name is Wayne. He's a Green Bay Packer fan.
是的，我同意这一点。确实如此。而且，我现在订婚了。他叫韦恩，是绿湾包装工队的球迷。
Does he work in the market?
他在市场工作吗？
No.
不。
Does he work days?
他上白班吗？
Days, yes.
是的，白班。
How is it? It's hard to start a relationship.
感觉怎么样？开始一段关系很难吧。
Very hard, very hard. It's just Friday and Saturday, really, that we see each other.
非常难，非常难。真的只有周五和周六我们能见面。
Can I check back in with you?
我可以以后再找你聊吗？
Yeah, go ahead.
可以，没问题。
It's one o'clock in the morning, and I'm with Henry again. He's taking a quick break.
凌晨一点，我又和亨利在一起。他正忙里偷闲。
I ordered lunch, I've got Guido here, and that makes tonight.
我点了午饭，我有圭多在这里，这就是今晚。
It's one o'clock in the morning and you just ordered lunch.
凌晨一点，你刚点了午饭。
Yes, yes. So everything is going smooth. Tomatoes are on fire.
是的。所以一切进展顺利。西红柿很火。
Still?
还是吗？
Yeah. We're sold out and they didn't come off the truck.
是啊。我们卖光了，而且货都没下卡车。
This is the point in the night where the market really changes. There are none of those people buying fancy stuff for high-end restaurants and specialty Manhattan stores. They're all gone. There's no more high-end guys like Jeff inspecting every carrot.
这是市场真正发生转变的时刻。那些为高档餐厅和曼哈顿特色商店购买高档货的人都不见了。像杰夫那种检查每一根胡萝卜的高端买家也不在了。
A whole new group of buyers enters the market now. And they're buying for not-so-fancy places-- bodegas and grocery stores in working class neighborhoods, pushcart vendors. They're not quite as concerned with getting the best possible quality. They want a good price.
现在一大群新买家进入市场。他们为那些不那么高档的地方采购——工人社区的小商店、杂货店和流动小贩。他们不像之前那样关注极致的质量，他们想要好价格。
It's in this second phase that the dynamic between sellers and buyers starts to shift. Remember early in the night, when Eddie One-Way had to go searching for someone to sell him pears? Over the next couple hours, it's the reverse. The sellers are looking for the buyers. And this, says a warehouse man named Thomas Kilgaren--
在第二阶段，买卖双方的动态开始转变。记得夜里早些时候，埃迪·单行道必须四处寻找卖家买梨吗？接下来的几个小时则是反过来的。卖家开始寻找买家。这是仓库员工托马斯·基尔加伦所说的——
Nickname Killer--
外号“杀手”——
Is the time to see who is a great salesman and who's not.
是时候看看谁是好推销员，谁不是了。
There's some guys down here that couldn't sell life insurance to the Kennedys. Know what I mean? But there's some that are pretty good. If you could sell something that somebody doesn't want, that's a good salesman. I come down here looking for lettuce, you sell me lettuce-- any moron could do that. Sell me something that I don't want-- you know what? That's a salesman.
有些人在这根本卖不掉任何东西。你知道我的意思吧？但有些人很厉害。如果你能把别人不需要的东西卖出去，那才是好推销员。我来这找生菜，你卖我生菜——任何笨蛋都能做到。卖我一些我根本不需要的东西——你知道吗？那才是销售。
Selling something that no one wants? That is exactly what a guy named Mike Sack, Big Mike, is trying to do right now. We catch up with him toward the end of the night.
卖出别人不需要的东西？这正是迈克·萨克（大迈克）现在试图做的事。我们在夜色临近尾声时赶上了他。
Earlier in the night, buyers were begging Big Mike to lower his prices, and he didn't. He refused. And it worked out pretty well for him. He sold a lot of Red Globe grapes and mangoes, and he made a killing in persimmons. But now that daylight's approaching, he's got piles and piles of oranges from Chile, and he's the one begging. He's pleading with one of his regular carports, a guy named Amerigo Perrera, to buy some of those oranges. Amerigo is pretty clear about his wishes.
夜里早些时候，买家曾求着大迈克降价，他没降。他拒绝了。这对他很有效，他卖出了很多红地球葡萄和芒果，在柿子上也大赚了一笔。但随着黎明临近，他还有成堆来自智利的橙子，现在轮到他求人了。他乞求他的常客阿梅里戈·佩雷拉买点橙子。阿梅里戈的意愿很明确。
No oranges.
不要橙子。
You've got to give in, Amerigo, today. You've got to be nice.
阿梅里戈，今天你得让步，得通情达理点。
What part of no oranges don't you understand?
你听不懂什么叫不要橙子吗？
I'll give you one pallet.
我给你一托盘。
No! Stop playing.
不！别闹了。
Be nice today. Be nice in front of the camera. There's a lady present.
今天客气点。在镜头前表现好点，有女士在场。
Shut up already.
闭嘴吧。
Can I give you one for $18?
我能给你一箱18美元吗？
No, Mike, no.
不，迈克，不要。
Just be nice.
客气点。
No.
不要。
Why?
为什么？
I don't need it today.
我今天不需要。
One skid only.
就一托盘。
Stop it, stop it, stop it. This stuff is being recorded, you understand?
住手，别再闹了。东西正在录制，你懂吗？
Yeah, but they just want to see, you know, and I've give you one skid. Be nice for the microphone, Amerigo. Amerigo, one skid. How about a 56.
是啊，但他们只是想看，我给你一托盘。对着麦克风表现好点，阿梅里戈。阿梅里戈，一托盘，56怎么样？
Why don't you stop playing around already? No.
你能不能别再闹了？不。
How about a 56? Amerigo!
56怎么样？阿梅里戈！
No!
不！
At around 4 AM, all of the sellers in the market find themselves pretty much in the same situation as Big Mike. Tired and with too many oranges. Listen to Henry-- so tired.
凌晨4点左右，市场里的所有卖家发现自己和迈克处于同样的境地。疲惫不堪，橙子堆积如山。听听亨利——太累了。
Oranges. Oranges are moving slow, so you know, you try to give everybody some oranges. Even if they don't want it, they're taking them. You know what I mean? Poor couple. This is, like, what time do you go to bed at night?
橙子。橙子卖得慢，所以你得试着塞给每个人一些橙子。即使他们不想要，也得收下。你知道我的意思吧？这对可怜的夫妇。这是，你晚上几点睡觉？
What time I go to bed? Probably like 11.
我几点睡觉？大概11点吧。
So this is like your nine o'clock. You know? I hate the day.
所以这就好比你的九点钟。你知道吗？我讨厌白天。
Wait, you hate the day?
等等，你讨厌白天？
Oh, I hate it.
哦，我讨厌。
What do you hate about the day?
你讨厌白天的什么？
I don't know. The sun, everything. I get a headache. How are you, my friend? I just don't like the sun. I don't like it. I mean, I like it, but you know, like now, if the sun came up, I hate it. The morning, I ain't into. I like the dark.
我不知道。太阳，所有一切。我头疼。你好吗，朋友？我就是不喜欢太阳。我不喜欢它。我是说，我喜欢它，但你看现在，如果太阳升起来，我就讨厌。早晨，我不喜欢。我喜欢黑暗。
At 5 AM, Henry heads home. He rakes some leaves in the front yard, and then heads to sleep just as the sun comes out.
清晨5点，亨利回家了。他在前院耙了一些落叶，然后在阳光出来时上床睡觉。
And later that day, a fancy grocery store in Greenwich, Connecticut might have some very nice, but kind of pricey, tomatoes. A high-end restaurant in Manhattan may be offering the chef's tomato bisque.
那天晚些时候，康涅狄格州格林威治的一家高档杂货店可能会有非常不错但价格昂贵的西红柿。曼哈顿的一家高档餐厅可能会提供主厨特制西红柿浓汤。
But further out, in poorer neighborhoods in South Boston, Brooklyn, Queens, tomatoes will be very hard to come by. Oranges, though, will be very cheap. And there will be lots of them.
但在南波士顿、布鲁克林、皇后区的贫困社区，西红柿会非常难买到。不过橙子会非常便宜，到处都是。
Chana Joffe-Walt and Adam Davidson of Planet Money, which is a co-production of our radio show and NPR news. You can hear them three times a week speaking in language anybody can understand about the human drama that's part of all kinds of economic systems at their podcast at www.npr.org/money.
以上是来自Planet Money的查娜·乔夫-沃尔特和亚当·戴维森，这是我们节目与NPR新闻的联合制作。你可以在每周三次的播客中收听他们用通俗易懂的语言讲述各类经济体系背后的真实故事，网址是 www.npr.org/money。
Act Two. It Was a Dark and Smoky Night.
第二幕：黑暗而烟雾弥漫的夜晚。
Jenifer Hixson told this story about the random kinds of things that can happen in the middle of the night at The Moth, where people get on stage and tell personal stories in front of an audience.
詹妮弗·希克森在“飞蛾”讲述了这个关于深夜里可能发生的随机事件的故事，“飞蛾”是一个人们上台在观众面前讲述个人故事的节目。
I reached over and secretly undid my seatbelt. And when his foot hit the break at the red light, I flung open the door and I ran. I had no shoes on. I was crying. I had no wallet. But I was OK, because I had my cigarettes.
我悄悄解开安全带。当他在红灯前踩下刹车时，我猛地推开车门跑了。我没穿鞋，在哭，没带钱包。但我没事，因为我有香烟。
When you live with someone who has a temper, a very bad temper, a very, very bad temper, you learn to play around that. You learn, this time I'll play possum, and next time I'll just be real nice, or I'll say yes to everything, or you make yourself scarce, or you run. And this was one of the times when you just run.
当你和一个脾气火爆的人生活在一起时，非常火爆，坏到极点的脾气，你就会学会如何应对。你会学到，这次我装死，下次我就乖巧点，或者对一切都说好，或者让自己消失，或者逃跑。而这是你不得不逃跑的时刻之一。
And as I was running, I thought, this was a great place to jump out. Because there were big lawns and there were cul-de-sacs, and sometimes he would come after me, and drive, and yell stuff at me to get back in, get back in, and I was like, no. I'm out of here. This is great. And I went and hid behind a cabana and he left.
我在跑的时候想，这里真是跳车的好地方，因为这里有大草坪和死胡同。有时他会开车追我，对我大喊大叫让我上车，而我心想，不，我离开这里了。太棒了。我躲到了一个更衣室后面，他开走了。
And I started to walk in this beautiful neighborhood. It was 10:30 at night. And there was no sound except for sprinklers. Ch, ch, ch, ch, brrrrr. Ch, ch, ch, ch, brrrr. And I was enjoying myself, and enjoying the absence of anger, and enjoying these few hours I knew I'd have of freedom. And just to perfect it, I thought, I'll have a smoke. And then it occurred to me, with horrifying speed, I don't have a light!
我开始在这个美丽的街区走。当时是晚上10:30，除了洒水器的声音外一片寂静。嚓，嚓，嚓，嚓，嗡嗡嗡。嚓，嚓，嚓，嚓，嗡嗡嗡。我很享受，享受愤怒的消散，享受我知道自己能拥有的那几个小时的自由。为了让这一切更完美，我想，抽支烟吧。然后我以极快的速度意识到，我没有火！
Just then, as if in answer, I see a figure up ahead. Who is that? It's not him, OK. They don't have a dog. Who is that? What are they doing out on this suburban street? And the person comes closer, and I can see it's a woman. And then I can see she has her hands in her face. Oh, she's crying.
就在这时，仿佛回应我，我看到前方有一个人影。那是谁？不是他，没关系。他们没带狗。那是谁？他们在这个郊区的街道上做什么？那个人走近了，我能看出是个女人。然后我能看到她正双手掩面。哦，她在哭。
And then she sees me, and she composes herself, and she gets closer, and I see she has no shoes on. And just as she passes me, she says, you got a cigarette? And I say, you got a light? And she says, damn, I hope so.
接着她看到我，稳住情绪，走近了些。我看到她没穿鞋。就在她经过我身边时，她说，你有烟吗？我说，你有火吗？她说，该死，我希望有。
And then first she digs into our cutoffs in the front-- nothing. And then digs in the back, and then she has this vest on that has 50 million little pockets on it. She's checking and checking, and it's looking bad. She digs back in the front again-- deep, deep-- and she pulls out a pack of matches that have been laundered at least once. We open it up and there is one match inside.
然后她先翻了翻前面的兜——什么都没有。又翻了翻后面，接着她身上穿的那件背心有5000万个小口袋。她翻啊翻，情况不妙。她又翻了翻前面——深深地——掏出一盒至少被洗过一次的火柴。我们打开它，里面只有一根火柴。
OK. Oh my god. This takes on-- it's like Nassau. Now we've got to like, how are we going to do it? OK. And we hunker down. We crouch on the ground. And where's the wind coming from? We're stopping. I take out my cigarettes. Let's get the cigarettes ready. Oh, my brand, she says. And we both have our cigarettes at the ready.
好吧。天哪。这变得——就像拿骚。现在我们得，我们要怎么做？好。我们蹲下来，蜷缩在地上。风是从哪来的？我们停下来。我拿出香烟。把香烟准备好。哦，我抽的这个牌子，她说。我们俩都准备好了香烟。
She strikes once, nothing. She strikes again-- yes, fire! Puff, inhale. Mm, sweet kiss of that cigarette. And we sit there, and we're loving the nicotine, and we both need this right now.
她划了一次，没着。又划了一次——着了！抽上一口，吸进去。嗯，那口香烟的甜蜜之吻。我们坐在那儿，沉浸在尼古丁中，我们现在都需要这个。
Immediately we start to reminisce about our 30 second relationship. "I didn't think that was going to happen!" "Me neither!" "Oh, man, that was close!" "Oh, I'm so lucky I saw you!" "Yeah!'
我们立刻开始回忆这30秒的关系。“我没想到会这样！”“我也是！”“天哪，刚才太惊险了！”“我真幸运遇见你！”“是啊！”
Then she surprises me by saying, "What was the fight about?" And I say, "What are they all about?" And she said, "I know what you mean." She said, "Was it a bad one?" And I said, "You know, like medium." She said, "Oh."
然后她出乎意料地问我：“为什么吵架？”我说：“吵架还能为什么？”她说：“我明白你的意思。”她说：“很严重吗？”我说：“你知道，中等吧。”她说：“哦。”
And we start to trade stories about our lives. We're both from up north. We're both kind of newish to the neighborhood. This is in Florida. We both went to college. Not great colleges, but man, we graduated.
我们开始交换关于我们生活的琐事。我们都来自北方，对这个街区都有点陌生。这是在佛罗里达。我们都上了大学。虽然不是什么名牌大学，但好歹毕业了。
And I'm actually finding myself a little jealous of her, because she has this really cool job washing dogs. She had horses back home, and she really loved animals, and she wants to be a vet, and I'm like, man, you're halfway there! I'm a waitress at an ice cream parlor. So I don't know where I want to be, but I know it's not that.
我发现自己甚至有点嫉妒她，因为她有一份很酷的工作——帮狗洗澡。她在老家有马，她真的爱动物，想当一名兽医，我心想，伙计，你已经成功一半了！我是冰激凌店的服务员。我不知道我以后想做什么，但我知道肯定不是那份工作。
And then it gets a little deeper, and we share some other stuff about what our lives are like. Things that I can't ever tell people at home. This girl-- I can tell her the really ugly stuff, and she still understands how it can still be pretty. She understands, like, how nice he's going to be when I get home, and how sweet that'll be.
接着话题深入了一些，我们分享了一些关于生活的事情。那些我无法告诉家里人的事情。这个女孩——我可以告诉她那些丑陋的事，她依然能理解事情有时为何还是美好的。她理解，当我回到家时，他会对我多么好，那会是多么甜蜜。
We are chain smoking off each other. Oh, that's almost out, come on! And we go through this entire pack until it's gone, and then I say, "You know what? This is a little funny, but you're going to have to show me the way to get home. Because although I'm 23 years old, I don't have my driver's license yet, and I just jumped out right when I needed to." And she says, "Well, why don't you come back to my house and I'll give you a ride?" I say, "OK, great," and we start walking.
我们共抽一支烟。哦，快没了，快点！我们把这整盒烟抽完，然后我说：“你知道吗？这有点可笑，但你得带我回家。因为虽然我23岁了，但我还没拿到驾照，而且我跳车跳得正是时候。”她说：“好吧，那你跟我回我家，我开车送你？”我说：“好的，太棒了。”我们开始走。
And we get to this-- lots of lights. And the roads are getting wider and wider, and there's more cars, and I see lots of stores. You know, laundromats, and dollar stores, and EmergiCenters.
我们到达这里——到处是灯光。路越来越宽，车越来越多，我看到了很多商店。你知道，自助洗衣店、一元店、急诊中心。
Then we cross over U.S. 1, and she leads me to someplace, and I think, no! But yes. Carl's Efficiency Apartments. This girl lives there. And it's horrible, and it's lit up so bright, just to illuminate the horribleness of it. It's the kind of place where you drive your car right up, and the door's right there, and there's 50 million cigarette butts outside, and there's like doors one through seven, and you know behind every single door there's some horrible misery going on. There's someone crying or drunk or lonely or cruel. And I think, oh, God. She lives here. How awful.
接着我们穿过美国1号公路，她带我去了某个地方，我心想，别啊！但还是到了。卡尔公寓。这女孩住在那。这里很可怕，灯光亮得刺眼，只是为了照亮那里的恐怖。这地方是你把车直接开到门口，门就在那儿，外面有5000万个烟蒂，有1到7号门，你知道每扇门后都有可怕的苦难在发生。有人在哭，在醉，在孤独或残忍。我想，天哪。她住这儿。真可怕。
We go to the door, door number four, and she very, very quietly keys in. As soon as the door opens, I hear the blare of television come out, and on the blue light of the television, the smoke of a hundred cigarettes in that little crack of light.
我们来到4号门，她非常、非常安静地开了门。门一打开，电视的吵闹声传来，在电视的蓝光下，那道光缝里弥漫着上百支香烟的烟雾。
And I hear the man, and he says, "Where were you?" And she says," "Never mind, I'm back." And he says, "You all right?" And she says, "Yeah, I'm all right." And then she turns me and says, "You want a beer?" And he says, "Who the [BLEEP] is that?"
我听到那个男人说：“你去哪了？”她说：“别管了，我回来了。”他说：“你没事吧？”她说：“是的，我没事。”接着她转向我说：“想喝啤酒吗？”他问：“那是谁？”
And she pulls me over, and he sees me, and he says, "Oh, hey." I'm not a threat.
她把我拉过去，他看见我了，说：“哦，嘿。”我不是威胁。
Just then he takes a drag of his cigarette and I follow the cigarette down. And I'm surprised when I see, int he crook of his arm, a little boy, sleeping. A toddler. And I think, [GASP]. And just then, the girl reaches underneath the bed and takes out a carton, and she taps out the last pack of cigarettes in there. And on the way up, she kisses the little boy, and then she kisses the man. And the man says again, "You all right?" And she says, "Yeah. I'm just going to go out and smoke with her."
就在这时，他抽了口烟，我跟着他的视线看向香烟。当我看到他怀里抱着一个小孩在睡觉时，我很惊讶。一个蹒跚学步的孩子。我想，[喘气]。就在这时，女孩从床底下拿出一个纸箱，把里面最后一包香烟拿出来。在她起身时，她亲了亲那个小男孩，然后亲了亲那个男人。男人又问了一遍：“你没事吧？”她说：“是的，我只是要带她出去抽支烟。”
And so we go outside and sit amongst the cigarette butts and smoke. And I say, "Wow, that's your little boy?" And she says, "Yeah, isn't he beautiful?" And I say, "Yeah, he is. He is beautiful." "He's my light. He keeps me going," she says.
于是我们走到外面，坐在烟蒂中间抽烟。我说：“哇，那是你的小男孩吗？”她说：“是啊，他不是很漂亮吗？”我说：“是的，他很漂亮。他是我的光，他支撑着我前进。”她说。
We finish our cigarettes. She finishes her beer. I don't have a beer, because I can't go home with beer on my breath. And she goes inside to get the keys.
我们抽完了烟。她喝完了啤酒。我没喝啤酒，因为我不能带着酒气回家。她进去拿钥匙。
She takes too long in there getting the keys, and I think something must be wrong. And she comes out and she says, "Look, I'm really sorry. But um, like we don't have any gas in the car, it's already on E, and he needs to get to work in the morning, and um, you know, I'm going to walk to work as it is. So what I did was, though, here, look, I drew out this map for you. And you really, you're like a mile and a half from home, and um, if you walk three streets over, you'll be back on that pretty street, and you just take that, and you'll be fine."
她在里面拿钥匙花的时间太长了，我心想一定出事了。她出来说：“听着，真的很抱歉。但是呢，车里没汽油了，油表指针已经在E档了，他早上还得去上班，我也得走着去上班。不过，给你，看，我为你画了这张地图。你离家其实只有一英里半，只要走过三条街，你就能回到那条漂亮的街道，沿着它走就行了。”
And she also has wrapped up in toilet paper seven cigarettes for me. A third of her pack, I note. And a new pack of matches.
她还用卫生纸包了七支烟给我。我注意到，那是她那盒烟的三分之一。还有一盒新火柴。
And she tells me, "Goodbye!", and "That was great to meet you," and "How lucky," and "That was fun," and you know, "Let's be friends."
她跟我说：“再见！很高兴认识你，真幸运，真有趣。”还说“我们做朋友吧。”
And I say, "Yeah, OK!" and I walk away. But I kind of know we're not going to be friends. I might not ever see her again. And I kind of know, I don't think she's ever going to be a vet.
我说：“好的，没问题！”但我心里清楚我们不会成为朋友。我可能再也见不到她了。我也知道，我觉得她永远不会成为一名兽医。
And I cross, and I walk away. And maybe this would have seemed like a visit from my possible future and scary, but it kind of does the opposite. On the walk home I'm like, man. That was really grim over there.
我穿过马路走开。也许这本该看起来像是一个来自我可能的未来且可怕的景象，但实际上恰恰相反。回家的路上我心想，天哪，那边真是太阴郁了。
And I'm going home now to my nice boyfriend, and he's going to be so extra happy to see me. And we have a one-bedroom apartment, and we have two trees, and there's a yard. And we have this jar in the kitchen where there's like loose money that we can use for anything. Like we would never, ever run out of gas. And I don't have a baby, you know? So I can leave whenever I want.
我现在要回家找我那个可爱的男朋友了，他看到我一定会格外高兴。我们有一间一居室的公寓，有两棵树，还有一个院子。厨房里有个罐子，里面有零钱，我们可以用来买任何东西。就像我们永远、永远不会没油一样。而且我没有孩子，所以想什么时候走都可以。
I smoked all seven cigarettes on the way home. And people who have never smoked cigarettes just think ick, disgusting and poison. But unless you've had them, and held them dear, you don't know how great they can be, and what friends and comfort and kinship they can bring.
我在回家的路上抽完了所有七支烟。没抽过烟的人会觉得恶心，是毒药。但除非你曾经抽过，并把香烟视若珍宝，否则你不知道它们有多棒，能带来多少朋友、安慰和亲情。
It took me a long time to quit that the boyfriend, and then to quit smoking. And sometimes I still miss the smoking.
我花了很长时间才戒掉那个男朋友，然后才戒掉香烟。有时我还是很怀念抽烟的感觉。
Jenifer Hixson at The Moth. You can here more stories like this on The Moth's free weekly podcast at themoth.org. They also have a new weekly radio show, The Moth Radio Hour, that's on many public radio stations around the country.
以上是“飞蛾”节目的詹妮弗·希克森。你可以在 themoth.org 的“飞蛾”免费每周播客中收听更多类似的故事。他们还有一个新的每周广播节目“飞蛾广播小时”，在全国许多公共广播电台播出。
Coming up, the time of night in Iraq when you can fool yourself into thinking that you're not in Iraq at all. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下篇，在伊拉克，当你能自欺欺人地认为你根本不在伊拉克的那段夜色时光。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际的节目继续播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, The Middle of the Night. Stories that happen when most of us are already asleep.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的主题是“深夜”。那些在我们大多数人已经入睡时发生的故事。
We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three. The Early Bird Catches the Chicken
我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕：早起的鸟儿有炸鸡吃。
Now a story about that people staying up all night hoping for nothing more than a chicken sandwich. When the change Chick-Fil-A opens a new store, they encourage people to line up 24 hours ahead of time, at 6 AM the day before. And for 100 people who do that, Chick-Fil-A gives away coupons for a year of Chick-Fil-A. One combo meal per week. 52 coupons, which is worth, if you add it up, 260 bucks.
现在讲一个关于人们熬夜整晚只为一份炸鸡三明治的故事。每当Chick-Fil-A连锁店开新店时，他们鼓励人们提前24小时，在前一天的早上6点开始排队。对于前100名排队的人，Chick-Fil-A会送出一年的Chick-Fil-A优惠券，每周一份套餐。52张优惠券，算下来价值260美元。
Well, Dave Hill and Shaina Feinberg were curious about who comes out for that, because a lot of people do. Neither of them is real reporter. Shaina is a very funny writer. Dave is a musician and a comedian. But when a new Chick-Fil-A store opened in Orlando, Florida recently, they went down to stay up all night and see what happens.
戴夫·希尔和沙娜·费恩伯格很好奇谁会来参加，因为确实有很多人来。他们俩都不是正式记者。沙娜是一位非常幽默的作家，戴夫是一位音乐家和喜剧演员。但最近佛罗里达州奥兰多开了一家新的Chick-Fil-A时，他们亲自去熬了个通宵，看看会发生什么。
OK. It's about nine o'clock. Shaina's trying to set up the tent right now. I would totally help her, but I'm busy reporting. How's it going, Shaina?
好了，大约九点钟了。沙娜正在努力搭帐篷。我本可以帮她，但我正忙着报道。进展如何，沙娜？
Good.  I think we put this into here, and then we can-- this is where I don't get-- how does this bend?
不错，我觉得这个要塞进这里，然后我们就能——这就是我不明白的地方——这东西怎么弯？
Again, I would help, if I could, but I can't. I'm busy reporting. Can we interview you?
再一次，如果可以的话我会帮忙，但我不能，我正忙着报道。我们可以采访你吗？
What do you want to know about?
你想知道什么？
Do you know how to set up tents?
你知道怎么搭帐篷吗？
Yeah, actually I set that tent up.
是的，其实那个帐篷就是我搭的。
Do you know how to set up our tent?
你知道怎么搭我们的帐篷吗？
Yeah, I can set up your tent.
是的，我可以帮你搭。
That'd be awesome.
那太棒了。
The DJ will be shutting down about 11:30. At that time, most of the folks will sleep, and at roughly 4:30 in the morning, the DJ comes back, and we wake them up.
DJ将在11:30左右停止工作。那时，大多数人会睡觉，大约凌晨4:30，DJ回来，我们会把他们叫醒。
It becomes a family-friendly event. Especially in the summer, you'll see whole families out here. So you'll see a whole list of rules about, you know, no drinking, and certain behavior. There's lots of dance contests.
这成了家庭友好的活动。特别是在夏天，你会看到整个家庭都来这。所以你会看到一长串规则，比如不准喝酒，某些行为准则。还有很多舞蹈比赛。
It's 11:23. We're sitting here in the parking lot across from Chick-Fil-A, just to see it from afar, I guess. I'm going to sit closer to you, if you're comfortable with that.
现在是11:23。我们正坐在Chick-Fil-A对面的停车场里，我想大概是为了远距离观察吧。如果你觉得舒服的话，我要坐得离你近点。
Yeah, that's fine. I think we should describe what we see.
嗯，没问题。我觉得我们应该描述一下我们看到的景象。
Well, we're pretty much in like a regular strip mall parking lot. There's a Blockbuster. There's that that rib place that we ate earlier that I'm kind of regretting.
好吧，我们基本上是在一个普通的商场停车场里。这有个百视达，还有我们之前吃的那个肋排店，我有点后悔吃了。
Yeah. And basically, there's a lot of tents up.
是啊。基本上，有很多帐篷。
Easily the most tents I've ever seen in a fast food restaurant parking lot in my lifetime.
这绝对是我这辈子在快餐店停车场见过的最多的帐篷。
It's weird with radio. You've got to fill in the blanks. The visuals.
广播就是这样，你得填补空白，描述视觉画面。
We should we should go get some celery and break it, like old time radio.
我们应该去买点芹菜，弄碎它，就像老派广播那样。
So people will be like, what is that noise?
这样人们就会问，那是什么声音？
Oh. I just broke my arm in two for no apparent reason.
哦，我刚无缘无故把手臂弄断了。
Hello? Hello? Hi. I'm Dave.
喂？喂？你好，我是戴夫。
I'm Ken Perkins.
我是肯·珀金斯。
I'm Ann.
我是安。
But I call her Hanusha.
但我叫她哈努莎。
Hanusha?
哈努莎？
Hanusha, in Ukrainian, is Ann.
哈努莎在乌克兰语里就是安的意思。
Oh, I like that.
哦，我喜欢。
How long have you guys been married?
你们结婚多久了？
We aren't married.
我们没结婚。
We were married to somebody else. But he died, and she died. I think he gave her mushrooms or something.
我们之前都结过婚。但他死了，她也死了。我想是他给她吃了蘑菇之类的。
No!
不！
Poison mushrooms.
毒蘑菇。
No. My wife died of Alzheimer's just a little over a year ago. And then and her husband died two years ago.
不。我妻子死于阿兹海默症，刚过去一年多。然后，她的丈夫两年前去世了。
Three.
三年前。
She was lonesome, and I was lonesome, so we got our lonesomes together.
她很寂寞，我也很寂寞，所以我们就凑到一起了。
Was it love at first sight for you guys?
你们是一见钟情吗？
For me it was. But he didn't--
对我来说是。但他没——
Not for me, not for me. I learned to love her. It took me a while.
不是我，不是我。我学会去爱她。花了我一阵子。
Why, why? This one, I'm going wild for this one, and I've only been been here like three minutes.
为什么，为什么？这个，我对这一对真的非常感兴趣，虽然我只在这待了三分钟。
Are you married?
你们结婚了吗？
Well, we're like, no. We're not married. How would you say, as long as we're on the topic, how do you think we're doing as a couple? Like just from vibes, just work off of vibes. Go with your gut.
嗯，我们，没有，我们没结婚。既然聊到这个话题，你觉得我们这对怎么样？就从感觉上，直觉走。跟着直觉走。
You are a lovely couple.
你们是一对很可爱的情侣。
I think you're charming
我觉得你很有魅力。
Really? Just me charming, or together charming?
真的吗？只有我很有魅力，还是我们俩在一起有魅力？
You should have beautiful children together.
你们应该会有漂亮的孩子。
That's why we brought the tent. No, I'm just kidding. I'm going to play it slow.
这就是我们带帐篷的原因。不，我开玩笑的。我会慢慢来。
Oh, we're not really a couple.
哦，我们其实不是一对。
Taco Bell?
塔可钟？
That's my favorite.
那是我的最爱。
Taco Bell's your favorite? I'm going to pretend I didn't hear that.
塔可钟是你的最爱？我假装没听见。
What is your name?
你叫什么名字？
John.
约翰。
No, not that name. The cool one.
不，不是那个名字。那个酷的。
Veggie Oil Man, Clearwater, Florida.
植物油人，佛罗里达州克利尔沃特。
That's a pretty long nickname. Veggie OIl Man, Clearwater--
那是相当长的绰号。植物油人，克利尔沃特——
Florida.
佛罗里达。
What about such Vegman300?
那Vegman300怎么样？
U.S.A.
美国。
Do you love Chick-Fil-A?
你爱Chick-Fil-A吗？
I kind of do Been to about 32 grand openings.
我挺爱的。参加过大约32次盛大开业典礼。
32? Now, wouldn't the thing to do, rather than spend the money on all that travelling, is just save that money and put that money towards the chicken?
32次？那么，比起把钱花在到处旅游上，把钱存下来留着买鸡肉不是更好吗？
Travel's free. I got a Mercedes that runs on used cooking oil for free.
旅游是免费的。我有一辆奔驰车，是用免费的旧烹饪油跑的。
You have a what?
你有什么车？
I got a Mercedes, a diesel Mercedes. An '83 station wagon that runs on used cooking oil for free.
我有一辆奔驰，柴油奔驰。一辆83年的旅行车，用免费的旧烹饪油跑。
That's what you drove here tonight in?
你今晚就是开这车来的？
Yeah. That's what I go to the grand openings in.
是啊，我就是开这车去参加盛大开业典礼的。
Do you think anything crazy's going to happen in the middle of the night?
你觉得深夜会发生什么疯狂的事吗？
I don't know. This is a bad neighborhood.
我不知道，这是个糟糕的社区。
Is it?
是吗？
Yeah. As long as you stay in the parking lot, you'd be OK. But I wouldn't go out walking around outside.
是的。只要你待在停车场里，就没问题。但我不会去外面走。
Is there a lot of riffraff around here?
这附近有很多流氓吗？
Yeah.
有。
Is there a lot of riffraff here?
这里有很多流氓吗？
They said the hood is right across the street a couple blocks.
他们说黑人聚居区就在街对面几个街区远。
The hood?
黑人聚居区？
Yeah.
是啊。
What do you mean, the hood?
你说的黑人聚居区是什么意思？
You know. And across the street over the other way is the redneck trailer park.
你知道的。街对面那边是乡巴佬拖车公园。
What what goes on over there?
那边发生什么？
I don't know, but we've seen a lot of people over there earlier today.
我不知道，但今天早些时候我们看到很多人在那。
Oh, you went over to the redneck trailer park?
哦，你去过那个乡巴佬拖车公园？
No, we seen them when we got our food at the drive-through. They were hanging out over there drinking beer on the porch.
没有，我们在得来速买食物时看到的。他们在那上面喝啤酒。
I'm going to sleep.
我要去睡觉了。
Hello? OK. What's your name?
喂？好吧。你叫什么名字？
My name's Cole Naismith.
我叫科尔·奈史密斯。
And what time is it? Do you know what time it is?
现在几点了？你知道现在几点吗？
It's probably about 1:15.
大概1:15左右。
Is it like what you expected?
这和你想的一样吗？
I didn't know what to expect. I looked around and I thought, there's definitely a type here. And you're probably going to ask follow up questions about what that means. Because I feel like-- I feel like I don't want to be the type.
我不知道该期待什么。我环顾四周，心想，这里的人确实有某种类型。你可能还会问一些关于那意味着什么的后续问题。因为我觉得——我觉得我不想成为那种类型。
What is the type?
那是什么类型？
I feel like most of the people that I've seen here seem to be a little bit twiddling their thumbs in life, not just for 24 hours? Something as ridiculous as sitting out in front of a Chick-Fil-A makes you ask questions about, am I wasting my life? I don't want to look around and seem like I'm judging others' actions. But it definitely has caused me to be introspective about my own.
我觉得我在这里看到的大多数人似乎在生活中都有点无所事事，不仅仅是这24小时内？像坐在Chick-Fil-A前面做这种荒谬的事，让你质疑自己是否在浪费生命。我不想环顾四周，看起来像是在评判别人的行为。但它确实让我对自己的行为进行了反思。
Oh hey. This is Dave. It's about 4:15 AM and there's not much action going on right now. Shaina's back in the tent. Not sure what she's doing. Probably thinking about me, I guess. Tension's been-- not a bad tension. Just excitement, I guess, between us. It's been pretty incredible.
哦，嘿。我是戴夫。现在大约凌晨4:15，没什么动静。沙娜在帐篷里。不知道她在做什么，大概在想我吧。紧绷感一直——不是坏的紧张，只是一种兴奋感，我觉得，在我们之间。真是太不可思议了。
It's now 4:15, and everybody is sleeping, for the most part. I think it's going pretty well. I like Dave. He's so nice. Wish I could figure out if he was straight or gay. I can't really figure it out. But if I figured out if he was straight or gay, then I would totally set him up with someone. Just have to figure out what his type is, you know?
现在4:15了，大家基本上都睡着了。我觉得进展很顺利。我喜欢戴夫，他真好。希望我知道他是异性恋还是同性恋。我真的搞不清楚。但如果我能搞清楚，我就一定会给他介绍个对象。只需要弄清楚他喜欢哪种类型，你知道吧？
OK. Check this out.
好了，看看这个。
Have you ever looked with love in your heart?
你有怀着爱心看过世界吗？
This guy, it's like five in the morning. And this guy just came from out of nowhere and is screaming and preaching.
这人，才五点钟。这人不知从哪冒出来，在那尖叫传道。
Have you ever stolen anything?
你有没有偷过东西？
Yes!
是的！
Well, the Bible says that all thieves will end up in hell.
好吧，圣经说所有的盗贼最终都会下地狱。
I'm going to hell.
我要下地狱了。
Now folks, have you ever used God's name in a curse word? I want you to think about it like that. You don't curse Hitler's name. You don't curse bin Laden's name. But you use the name of God who gave you life and breath, who has allowed Chick-Fil-A to give away free meals, and you curse his name! Jesus Christ out on the cross! He paid--
各位，你们有没有在诅咒中用过神的名字？我希望你们好好想想。你们不会诅咒希特勒的名字。你们不会诅咒本·拉登的名字。但你们却用了赐予你们生命和气息的神的名字，他允许Chick-Fil-A提供免费餐点，而你们却在诅咒他的名！耶稣基督被钉在十字架上！他付出了——
Excuse me--oh.
打扰一下——哦。
For your sins and my sins! Folks, did you know the Bible says that God sees hatred as murder? A lot of you right now hate me this morning for coming out here and sharing the gospel with you, therefore committed murder in your hearts!
为了你的罪和我的罪！伙计们，你们知道圣经说神将仇恨视为谋杀吗？你们很多人现在因为我今早出来与你们分享福音而恨我，因此你们心里已经犯了谋杀罪！
Excuse me.
打扰一下。
All the sins of the world were placed upon Jesus Christ.
世上所有的罪都归在了耶稣基督身上。
Oh, excuse me. Can I interview you?
哦，打扰一下。我可以采访你吗？
Sure.
当然。
Um, what brings you to Chick-Fil-A?
嗯，是什么把你带到Chick-Fil-A来的？
To preach the gospel.
来传播福音。
How did you know to come now? Did you come because, were you just driving by?
你怎么知道现在过来？你是因为只是开车路过吗？
No, because I knew there was a crowd.
不，因为我知道这有人群。
Oh, OK.
哦，好吧。
I'm Jason, by the way.
顺便说一下，我是杰森。
Oh, hey. Oh, yeah, I saw the name tag. I'm Dave.
哦，嘿。哦，是的，我看到名牌了。我是戴夫。
Nice to meet you, Dave.
很高兴见到你，戴夫。
Is this your first Chick-Fil-A opening?
这是你第一次参加Chick-Fil-A的开业典礼吗？
Yes. I woke them up for sure.
是的。我确实把他们叫醒了。
Yeah. That was kind of funny.
是的，那挺逗的。
I'm always a little loud.
我总是声音有点大。
Do you do this sort of thing often? Like go to, doesn't have to be a fast food restaurant, but like in public, yelling?
你经常做这种事吗？比如去，不一定是快餐店，但在公共场合大喊？
Well, I try not to make it look like I'm yelling. I'm trying to preach.
嗯，我尽量不让自己看起来像在大喊。我在尝试传教。
Well, not yelling. You're just making it so people can hear your voice in a loud way.
嗯，不是大喊。你只是在让人们以大声的方式听到你的声音。
I woke up my wife this morning. I said, babe, I'm going to Chick-Fil-A, and I'll be back right before I've got to go to work.
今天早上我把我妻子叫醒了。我说，宝贝，我要去Chick-Fil-A，我得在上班前赶回来。
And she was like, all right. I'm going back to bed.
她说，好吧，我要回去睡觉。
She's like, what? Yeah. Then she went back to bed.
她是说，什么？是的，然后她又去睡觉了。
OK. It is now 5:40 in the morning, and people are lined up to get their 52 coupons. And everyone is looking really, incredibly jazzed.
好了，现在是清晨5:40，人们排着队领取他们的52张优惠券。每个人看起来都非常、非常兴奋。
When I say count, we're going to count down from five, all right? Five! Four! Three! Two! One! Eat more chicken!
当我喊数字时，我们从五开始倒数，好吗？五！四！三！二！一！多吃鸡肉！
Hey Shaina, let's sing the song we wrote. Ready?
嘿，沙娜，我们唱写的那首歌吧。准备好了吗？
Yeah.
好。
All right. Here we go.
好的。我们开始。
[SINGING]
[歌唱]
Chick-Fil-A.
Chick-Fil-A。
If you like chicken, go to--
如果你喜欢鸡肉，就去——
Chick-Fil-A.
Chick-Fil-A。
If you like chicken, why not--
如果你喜欢鸡肉，为什么不——
Go to Chick-Fil-A!
去Chick-Fil-A！
Waffle fries and lemonade. These are just a couple of the items that they have available at Chick-Fil-A. And at first that carrot and raisin salad is a little bit suspicious.
华夫薯条和柠檬水。这些只是Chick-Fil-A提供的部分餐点。起初那份胡萝卜葡萄干沙拉有点可疑。
But you know what, I've tried it.  And as it turns out--
但你知道吗，我试过了。结果发现——
Quite delicious.
非常美味。
That's right. Chick-Fil-A, Chick-Fil-A...
没错。Chick-Fil-A，Chick-Fil-A...
[END SINGING]
[歌唱结束]
Dave Hill and Shaina Feinberg.
戴夫·希尔和沙娜·费恩伯格。
Act Four. Midnight Run.
第四幕：午夜奔袭。
A little while back, after we did a program that all took place at a rest stop on the side of the highway, we got an email from specialist Lindsay Freeland, who's in the Oregon National Guard, and who heard the episode by podcast from where she's stationed in Iraq. She wrote to us about the road trips that she goes on in her job, in the middle of the night, without real rest stops, to forward operating bases across the country. Quote, "It's late, it's dark, and it's not the normal to be up and driving to a destination. Here in Iraq, this is our military time for driving, late at night, due to the agreement between the American military and the Iraqi military to conduct most convoy operations at night to bring a normalcy back to the Iraqi local nationals."
不久前，在我们制作了一期全部在公路休息站录制的节目后，收到了一封来自国民警卫队专员琳赛·弗里兰的电子邮件，她是通过播客收听这期节目的，当时她驻扎在伊拉克。她写信告诉我们她在深夜里、没有真正休息的情况下，前往全国各前沿作战基地的护送任务。引用：“时间很晚了，天很黑，熬夜开车去目的地并不正常。在伊拉克，这是我们军事行动的时间，由于美军和伊拉克军方达成协议，大多数车队行动在晚上进行，以恢复伊拉克当地民众的正常生活。”
One of our producers, Nancy Updike, reached Lindsay Freeland on the phone and learned that she's 24. Just got to Iraq in July. Started doing these convoys in August, mostly transporting fuel. There are three people in her vehicle. She's a driver. There's also a gunner and a commander. And it's so noisy that they have to talk to each other over headsets for the whole trip.
我们的制片人南希·厄普代克通过电话联系上了琳赛·弗里兰，了解到她24岁。七月才到伊拉克，八月开始执行这些护送任务，主要运输燃料。她的车里有三个人。她是司机，还有一名炮手和一名指挥官。由于太吵，他们全程必须戴着耳机交流。
What's amazing is how huge these convoys are-- 20 to 100 trucks, plus another 11 military vehicles providing security, which is what Lindsay's in.
令人惊奇的是这些车队规模有多大——20到100辆卡车，加上另外11辆负责安保的军用车辆，也就是琳赛所在的车队。
It's a pretty amazing scene. I mean, especially when I'm like the front truck, and I can see this line of lights behind me, because we're so tightly compact within our convoy that we brighten up that whole night road. I always think of it that we're stringing through Iraq like Christmas tree lights. A bunch of white, big, bright lights snaking through the dark desert. And we usually are the biggest light out there, because not many local nationals like to drive at night.
场面非常震撼。尤其是当我在前导车上时，可以看到身后这一长串灯光，因为车队行驶得很紧凑，照亮了整个夜路。我常觉得我们就像圣诞树灯一样串在伊拉克。一串白色、硕大、明亮的灯光蜿蜒穿过黑暗的沙漠。我们通常是外面最亮的光源，因为没几个当地人喜欢在晚上开车。
You're saying local national, Iraqis?
你说当地人是指伊拉克人吗？
Right. And sometimes they're out there. There are not too many of them. And if we do see them, they're usually a lot nearer their own types of Iraqi rest stops, which are like their kind of markets or whatever. So that's the side of the road. Or a fuel station, which can be a tanker truck with a hose hooked onto it with a little kid ready to fuel up to make money for the day, and markets along the back of it.
对。有时他们也在那。没几个人。如果我们看到他们，他们通常离自己的类似伊拉克休息站的地方更近，那可能就是他们的市场之类的。所以这就在路边。或者加油站，那可能是一辆挂着软管的油罐车，旁边站着个小孩准备加油挣一天的钱，后面还有市场。
You'll just see these on the side of the road as you're driving?
你们开车时路边就能看到这些？
Yeah, exactly. They're just out in the middle of the desert, sometimes in the middle of nowhere. They're usually to the side of the road. It's their version a Starbucks or whatnot.
是的，完全正确。他们就在沙漠中间，有时在荒郊野外。通常在路边。那是他们版本的星巴克之类的。
In the email you sent to us, you said that the night convoys were part of an agreement between the U.S. military and the Iraqis. Explain that.
你在给我们的邮件里说，夜间车队是美军和伊拉克人之间协议的一部分。解释一下。
We conduct our operations at night. It's just our agreement so that we don't interrupt their life as much. Just because we are a really long and big convoy. So I mean, that is kind of a big deal, and that is kind of an interrupter, I guess you could say.
我们在晚上执行行动。这只是为了达成协议，这样我们就不会过多打扰他们的生活。因为我们是一个很长、规模很大的车队。所以这是件大事，也是个干扰，我想你可以这么说。
And they don't like us, and you can tell that. Because some traffic, if we're headed northbound, you know, they'll be going both ways in the southbound lane.
他们不喜欢我们，看得出来。因为一些交通，如果我们北上，他们会在南向车道双向行驶。
So basically, they would rather cram traffic going in two directions into one lane rather than try to share the lane that your convoy's in.
所以基本上，他们宁愿把两个方向的交通挤进一个车道，也不愿和你们的车队共享车道。
Right, exactly. They don't want to be near us. Because we have big cruiser weapons on our vehicles. We have bright lights. We try to be nice and try to turn off the left side or something, so we dim the lights for them.
没错，完全正确。他们不想靠近我们。因为我们的车辆上有大型武器，还有明亮的灯光。我们尽量友善点，关掉左侧灯光之类，把车灯调暗点。
So you're not kind of blinding other drivers.
所以你们不会晃到其他司机的眼睛。
Right, exactly. But usually they just don't like being near us, so they'll pull off the road completely and just turn their flashers on and wait for us to pass.
没错，完全正确。但通常他们就是不喜欢靠近我们，所以他们会完全驶离公路，打开危险警示灯，等着我们通过。
How many of these convoys have you done?
你执行过多少次这样的护送任务？
Probably 20 or 30. I mean, it can get pretty mundane. Now on eight hour missions, they're like a quickie, you know, really fast.
可能有20或30次。其实变得很乏味。八小时的任务，就像快餐一样，真的很快。
Because how long are the long ones?
因为长途的要多久？
The longest we've had is about 15 hours. It seems very, very long and drawn out, and your legs get pretty tired staying in that one position for a long time when you only have one stop throughout those 15 to 16 hours, you know.
最长的大约有15个小时。看起来非常、非常漫长，当在这15到16小时内只有一个休息站时，长时间保持那个姿势，腿真的很累。
But for the most part, we are pretty energy drink fulfilled, with a cooler next to our gunner's turret, and we just reach behind him, and grab our energy drinks. And I think I drink probably about three energy drinks in one convoy. Which is not good, you know. Not good for you. But it helps. Especially on the boring convoys, and the long, long drawn out convoys.
但大多数情况下，我们靠能量饮料补充体力，炮塔旁放着冷藏箱，我们就在炮手后面伸手去拿能量饮料。我觉得我一个车队任务大概喝三罐。这不好，你知道的，对身体不好。但确实有帮助，特别是在无聊或漫长的任务中。
I mean, we always usually have at least one or two breakdowns of our third country national supply trucks. I think one convoy, our 15 hour convoy, what we had probably about seven or eight breakdowns. It was ridiculous.
我们通常至少会有一两辆第三国供应卡车抛锚。我觉得有一次15小时的任务，我们大概有七八次抛锚，太离谱了。
Is there ever a time, when you're driving or you're stopped, that you almost forget where you are?
有没有什么时候，当你开车或停下来时，差点忘了自己在哪？
Oh yeah, for sure. Sometimes I feel like I'm driving in, you know, the desert of the U.S., like Arizona or something like that. You know, it looks like a normal highway within the States. Because A, it's dark, and B, it's just a normal paved road. Yeah, it's not as kept up as well as how the states keep it up, and half the road isn't even painted where the stripes are supposed to be, but for the most part, it reminds you of a normal highway.
哦，有，当然。有时我觉得自己正在美国沙漠里开车，就像亚利桑那州之类的。你知道，看起来就像美国境内的普通公路。因为A，天黑，B，就是一条普通的铺装道路。是的，维护得不如美国国内那么好，有一半的路面甚至连划线的漆都没有，但大多数时候，这让你想起普通公路。
And so sometimes I feel like I'm on a long roadtrip. Sometimes I feel like I'm driving a big freight truck, like if I was a truck driver back home, you know. It's usually a pretty quick feeling, because you can be brought back pretty fast.
所以有时我觉得自己在进行一场长途旅行。有时我觉得自己在开重型货运卡车，如果我是国内的卡车司机的话。通常这种感觉转瞬即逝，因为很快就会被拉回现实。
There's tires everywhere. They line the road. I mean, I'm not even kidding when I say that. Most Iraqis, they run out their tires until they're completely destroyed to smithereens, and so they'll just leave those pieces on the side of the road. There's no type of cleanup crew to come clean up the trash on the road. There's no type of officer to come pick up the destroyed tire that's in the right lane.
到处都是轮胎。它们铺满了道路。我说真的，一点没夸张。大多数伊拉克人把轮胎用到彻底损毁为止，所以他们就把碎片留在路边。没有清理队来清理路上的垃圾。没有警察来捡右车道上的废轮胎。
So that's usually just what seems to bring me back to being in Iraq. And then, you know, sometimes I look down-- wait, I have my body armor on. I'm in still in Iraq.
所以这通常就是让我回想起在伊拉克的原因。然后，你知道，有时我低头——等等，我穿着防弹衣，我还在伊拉克。
Specialist Lindsay Freeland of Alpha Company 141 with the Organ National Guard in Iraq, talking with Nancy Updike.
以上是伊拉克国民警卫队141旅Alpha连的琳赛·弗里兰专员，与南希·厄普代克的谈话。
Act Five. Bump in the Night.
第五幕：夜半惊魂。
We end our show today with this story about a very common experience-- staying up all night with a sick child. One of our producers, Jane Feltes, tells what happened to her and her parents back when she was six years old and her parents were 26. They were visiting family friends with holidays in the UP, Michigan's Upper Peninsula, which is the part of the state that isn't, you know, the mitten. Here's Jane.
今天节目的最后，我们要讲述一个非常普遍的经历——通宵照顾生病的幼儿。我们的制片人之一简·费尔特斯讲述了她六岁那年，她父母26岁时发生的事。当时他们正在密歇根州上半岛探亲，也就是该州不是“手套”形状的那部分。以下是简的故事。
This night, a lot of adults wanted to go out, so my mom volunteered to babysit about seven of us kids altogether. And all the kids' bunks were upstairs in this old, old log cabin, and the staircase to get upstairs had no railing. It was just kind of, shoots out into the middle of the room.
那天晚上，许多大人想出去，我妈妈主动要求照顾我们总共七个孩子。所有孩子的铺位都在这间古老的木屋楼上，通往楼上的楼梯没有扶手。它只是直接对着房间中央。
And I remember we all got our pajamas on, and we all ran upstairs.
我记得我们都穿上睡衣，跑上楼。
And I'm not exactly sure if you slipped or got bumped by the herd of children running up the stairs--
我不太确定你是滑倒了还是被一群跑上楼的孩子撞了——
This is my mom.
这是我妈妈。
But you were falling. And I managed to grab your ankle as your head smashed into the concrete floor. From about eight feet up.
但你摔倒了。我抓住了你的脚踝，当时你的头狠狠地撞在了混凝土地板上，从大约八英尺高的地方摔下来。
And everybody, all the kids were just frozen on the stairs. And-- ugh, this is creepy.
所有的孩子都冻在了楼梯上。呃，太可怕了。
So I had to do something. So I'm trying to comfort you, and then you'd be crying and crying-- I mean, like, screaming. And then you'd say, oh, I'm so sleepy. You'd get really calm and still, and kind of go limp a little bit. And then you'd start screaming again.
所以我必须做点什么。我试图安抚你，但你在不停地哭——我的意思是，在尖叫。然后你说，哦，我好困。你变得非常平静，有点瘫软。然后你又开始尖叫。
My part, embarrassingly, was I was drinking at Pine Stump Junction.
尴尬地说，我当时正在Pine Stump Junction喝酒。
You remember the name of it?
你还记得那个名字？
Pine Stump Junction. Everybody knows that place.
Pine Stump Junction。大家都知道那个地方。
So that's my dad. My mom somehow piled seven kids into a car that wasn't even hers, that was sitting in the driveway, and drove us all to the bar. And she didn't know how to get there, but an eight year old in the car did, so he instructed her. And my mom and my dad, and me and my brother-- we just drove to the nearest hospital, which was in Newberry, which was a really, really tiny town in the Upper Peninsula.
这就是我爸爸。我妈妈不知怎么把七个孩子塞进了一辆根本不是他们的车里，这车当时就停在车道上，把我们都载到了那个酒吧。她不知道怎么去那，但车上一个八岁的小孩知道，所以他指挥她。我妈妈和爸爸，还有我和哥哥——我们直接开车去了最近的医院，在纽伯里，那是上半岛一个非常、非常小的镇子。
And you weren't quite unconscious, but you weren't conscious. And you weren't responsive or alert. And when we got down to Newberry, it was after hours in the clinic, and night was following, and the only guy there, physician, was some retired part-time guy. Older fellow.
你并没有完全失去知觉，但也并非清醒。你没有反应也不警觉。当我们到达纽伯里时，诊所已经下班了，夜色正浓，那里唯一的医生是个退休的兼职医生，是个年长的人。
So I had just started practicing dentistry, and the things that were just fresh in my mind from the medical school aspect of my education-- so it was very, very scary.
所以我刚开始牙医实习，医学院教育给我留下的知识还历历在目——所以当时真的、真的很可怕。
wait,
等等，
Wait, what kind of stuff?
等等，什么方面？
Well, like when you're looking at a patient, and they're kind of alert, and they're kind of talking, and then one of their eyes dilates, and they start to slow down and slur a little bit, and then the other eye dilates, and they're gone.
嗯，比如当你观察病人时，他们看似警觉，也能交流，然后其中一只眼睛开始放大，他们开始变慢，说话开始含糊，接着另一只眼睛也放大了，然后他们就没意识了。
And was it happening?
当时发生这种情况了吗？
No.
没有。
Oh.
哦。
No, no. But I was checking every five minutes. And I would snap my fingers and see if you were-- just because you were just listless. You just were a little while lump.
没有。但我每五分钟就检查一次。我会打响指看你有没有反应——只是因为你太无精打采了。你就是一团小肉球。
So they told my dad that they weren't even going to call a radiologist until the morning to do X-rays. And they wanted to just keep me there, overnight, like, sitting there.
所以他们告诉我爸爸，他们甚至不打算叫放射科医生直到早上做X光检查。他们只想把我留在那里过夜，就那样坐着。
And I just-- I couldn't believe that I was hearing this. That he was going to make us wait until eight or nine o'clock the next morning before we even called the radiologist. This was up in the middle of BFE, and it was at night. And I thought, this is bad. Because she could be gone by morning. And I can't do nothing overnight.
我简直不敢相信自己听到了什么。他竟然要让我们等到第二天早上八九点，连放射科医生都不叫。这可是位于荒郊野外，而且还是晚上。我想，这太糟糕了。因为到早上她可能就没救了。我整晚什么都做不了。
So I called the nurse in, and your mother and I talked about it a little bit, and then we called him in and said, we're taking her.
所以我把护士叫进来，你妈妈和我商量了一下，然后我们叫医生进来，说我们要带她走。
And I remember thinking, we're going to be out in the middle of the UP now. Nowhere near a hospital. In a car with a sick little girl and another little boy. And we have something like a five and a half hour drive to get home.
我还记得我心想，我们现在要在上半岛中间了，离医院十万八千里。车里有个病重的小女孩和另一个小男孩，我们还得开五个半小时的车才能回家。
Home, at the time, was Ann Arbor, Michigan, where my dad went to school and where they knew there was a trauma center where if, you know, worst case scenario was happening, something could be done about it.
当时我们的家在密歇根州安阿伯，我爸爸在那里上学，他们知道那里有个创伤中心，如果——你知道，如果发生最坏的情况，那里能采取措施。
And I remember very little from that night, but just coming to in little flashes in the first hospital, and in the car. And I remember everything looked like I was in that movie Tron. You know, it was all very, like, black, and the edges of everything kind of glowed bright neon colors. And I wasn't walking, and I wasn't really moving much, except to throw up.
我还记得那晚很少的内容，只是在第一家医院和车里偶尔闪过的记忆。我记得一切看起来就像我在电影《创：战纪》里一样。你知道，一切都是黑漆漆的，边缘闪着明亮的霓虹灯光。我没法走路，除了呕吐外，基本上动弹不得。
The first leg of the trip was really-- actually scary to me. Because the UP in the middle of the night-- there's no lights. There's nobody there. It's desolate. And you kind of look for lights in houses. Kind of trying to get an idea of the time. You know, our car at the time didn't have a clock in it.
旅程的第一段真的——对我来说其实很可怕。因为午夜的上半岛——没有灯，没有人，一片荒凉。你会寻找房子里的灯光，试图了解时间。你知道，我们当时的车上没有时钟。
Oh really?
哦真的吗？
Oh yeah. Cars didn't use to have clocks on the dashboard, and I didn't use to wear a watch. So I didn't really even know what time it was. So you'd kind of watch the windows and see if there's people up. Of course there was no traffic. I don't think we stopped.
哦，是啊。以前的车仪表盘上没时钟，我也不戴表。所以我甚至不知道几点了。所以你只能盯着窗外看有没有人醒着。当然，路上没有车。我想我们没停下来。
If we did, we stopped for fuel. That's kind of a long trip. So I know we had to have stopped for fuel. But we didn't really need-- anything. Didn't need anything. There was no need to stop.
如果停了，那也是为了加油。那是很长的旅程。所以我知道我们肯定停下来加油。但我们真的不需要——任何东西。不需要任何东西，没有必要停下来。
It was still really scary. I remember wondering if you were going to be trapped, somehow. Like that same little girl would be trapped with a brain injury. I mean, you couldn't walk at that point because you were so dizzy. But of course, in my mind, I'm connecting that with you can't walk. You know? Things aren't going to work anymore.
依然非常可怕。我记得我在想你是不是会被永远困住。就像那个小女孩会被大脑损伤困住一样。我的意思是，你当时无法行走，因为太头晕了。但在我脑海里，我把这和无法行走联系在一起。你知道吧？事情不会再正常运转了。
And I don't think your dad and I talked about any of that on the way home.
我想你爸爸和我回家的路上没聊这些。
I worried that there was an undiagnosed spinal injury, and that you would have to fight with a wheelchair your whole life. I worried that you'd have migraines and puke all your life. Which you do.
我担心是不是有未诊断的脊柱损伤，你这辈子都得坐轮椅。我担心你会偏头痛，呕吐一辈子。而你确实如此。
That's true. That was one of the main lasting effects of the accident. We got to the hospital, and they did a CT scan, and found that I had what's called a contrecoup lesion in my brain. And I wasn't really able to walk for a couple of weeks. And then I didn't get back to school regularly-- I think I was out for like a month.
那是真的。那是那次事故遗留的主要影响之一。我们到了医院，他们做了CT扫描，发现我的大脑里有一种叫“对冲性损伤”的东西。我有几周几乎无法走路。然后我没能正常回到学校——我想我请假了一个月。
So that first night driving home after the accident just led to hundreds and hundreds of nights like that, where I was up all night sick. I started getting really bad migraines. I would always get them, like, two, three, four in the morning. I would wake up and I'd see these sparkly lights kind of around the edge of my field of vision. Then there's a little bit of, like, TV v static that gets bigger and bigger over the course of an hour until I'm blind. And then it's like worst-- pain so bad that it makes you throw up.
所以那次事故后回家的第一晚，导致了后来几百个那样的夜晚，我通宵生病。我开始变得非常严重的偏头痛。我总是会在凌晨两点、三点、四点发作。我会醒来，看到视野边缘闪烁着光点，然后就像电视雪花点一样，在一小时内越来越大，直到我失明。接着是糟糕的——疼痛剧烈到让你呕吐。
And that whole thing is like a big cluster [BLEEP]. Because you'd come in the bedroom and bend over me and say, I'm seeing those lights, Mom, I'm seeing those lights.
那整个过程简直是一团糟。因为你会走进卧室，俯身对着我说，妈妈，我看到那些光了，我看到那些光了。
I do remember, as a mom, in the middle of the night when you would wake me up about that, feeling like a good mom. Because I just got up. You know? And I just remember as a kid when I was sick, a lot of times people didn't have time for that.
作为一个妈妈，在深夜你要因为那个把我叫醒时，我确实记得感觉自己是个好妈妈。因为我只是起床了，你懂吗？我记得小时候当我生病时，很多时候大人们都没时间管我。
What do you mean?
什么意思？
Here's a blanket. You know? Go get a puke bowl. And kind of being sick by myself. So I know I do remember feeling good that I wasn't going to be that kind of mom.
给你个毯子，你知道吗？去拿个呕吐盆。只能自己一个人病着。所以我确实记得因为自己不会成为那样的妈妈而感觉很好。
It was nice of them to get up with me like that. But after a while, it just started to seem pointless, because there wasn't really anything that they could do to make me feel better.
他们能那样陪我起床挺好的。但过了一阵子，这开始显得毫无意义，因为他们真的没什么能做的来让我感觉好点。
My mom says when you do get up to take care of kids in the middle of the night, it can feel like you're the only people awake in the whole world. And that was true the first night, when we drove through the Upper Peninsula. And it was true for all the nights my mom got up with me. And it's true now that I have to deal with it all by myself.
我妈妈说当你深夜起床照顾孩子时，感觉就像你是全世界唯一醒着的人。那第一晚我们开车穿过上半岛时是真的。我妈妈起床陪我的所有夜晚也是真的。现在我必须独自面对这一切，也是真的。
Jane Feltes.
简·费尔特斯。
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sara Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Aaron Scott. Seth Lind is our production manager, Emily Condon our office manager. Our music consultant is Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩制作，参与制作的还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、阿莉莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自亚伦·斯科特。塞思·林德是我们的制作经理，艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。我们的音乐顾问是杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who comes to me every week as I'm preparing the credits of the program and pleads with me--
我们的网站是 thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。我们节目的WBEZ管理监督是我们老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他每周在我在准备节目制作名单时来找我，并恳求我——
nice today. Be nice for the microphone.
今天客气点。在麦克风前表现好点。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间带来更多《美国生活》的故事。